You know, if you were to walk into a room full of tech CEOs today and just ask them if we're on the verge of a runaway intelligence explosion.
Oh, they all say yes.
Right. They would look you right in the eye and say, absolutely. You know, that whole sci-fi moment where AI gets smart enough to improve its own code and progress just instantly skyrockets to infinity.
Yeah, the singularity. It's all anyone talks about.
Exactly. But if you look at the actual mathematical threshold required for a machine to infinitely improve itself. We aren't even close. Let's be real. We are actually failing the test right now by six percentage points.
Which is such a sobering reality check, honestly. I mean, for years, this entire debate around runaway AI has been completely dominated by philosophical arguments.
Just gut feelings, mostly.
Right. Gut feelings. People arguing over what it fundamentally means to be smart or, you know, they pointed a chat bot writing a poem and just assume we're like six months away from the singularity.
Yeah. So our mention for today's deep dive is to slice right through all that hype. We're looking at a brand new, highly disciplined economics paper. It was published on September 14th, 2026.
Hot off the presses.
Yeah, literally. It's called The Economics of Recursive Self-Improvement by Tom Cunningham and his eight co-authors at METR, the Elasticity Institute.
And the core contribution of this paper, the real paradigm shift here, is that it takes a very messy, abstract, frankly, kind of chaotic argument about our future and it turns it into a measurable mathematical quantity.
Which is wild.
It is. They basically built a framework to track the intelligence explosion the exact same way a central bank would track inflation or GDP.
I love that. And we're going to give you their headline answer right up front today, just so you have an anchor for everything we are about to talk about. Are we currently in a runaway sci-fi intelligence explosion?
The math says not yet.
Not yet. But the number they are tracking is undeniably rising. Okay, let's unpack this.
So to wrap our heads around the math of the future, we kind of have to ground ourselves in the economic realities of the past first.
Right, the background context.
Exactly. There's this foundational line of thinking from Avion Jones and Jones back in 2017. They modeled how automating the production of ideas could lead to accelerating or even explosive growth.
Be optimistic, you.
But that optimistic theory sits on top of this massive, honestly somewhat depressing counterweight in economics. There's a famous paper by Bloom and his co-authors called Our Ideas Getting Harder to Find.
And the answer is yes, they are.
Yeah, very much yes. They documented this reality that in traditional industries, I mean, whether you're looking at crop yields in agriculture or, you know, squeezing more transistors onto a semiconductor research, productivity is falling.
It's like we're running on a treadmill that just keeps speeding up.
Exactly. We have to throw an ever increasing number of human researchers and billions more dollars at a problem just to maintain a flat, constant rate of growth.
Because the low hanging fruit is already gone.
Right. To keep Moore's Law alive, the semiconductor industry has had to massively increase its R&D effort decade after decade.
So that brings us to the big question Cunningham and his team at METR are asking in this new 2026 paper. Is AI going to be the very first technology in human history to actually escape that historical trap?
Right. And to answer that, they use this incredibly clean graphical framework.
Yeah, I love how they laid this out. They basically map out AI development as a directed graph.
So think of it like an audio setup at a concert.
Oh, that's a good way to put it.
Yeah, you have your microphones, your amps, your speakers. In their graph, the different pieces of equipment are the nodes, the outputs, things like algorithmic efficiency or AI capabilities.
And the cables connecting everything together.
Those are what economists call elasticities. It's just a measure of responsiveness. So how much does a percentage change in one input affect the output?
Right. Like if you turn up the mic volume by 10 percent, how much louder does the speaker get?
Exactly. And the math to figure out a feedback loop here is surprisingly simple. A feedback loop strength is just the product of the elasticities along it. You just multiply them.
And then the total elasticity is what you get when you sum over all those different loops.
Right. Which brings us to the knife edge. This is where the magic numbers come in. If the total elasticity of algorithmic improvement with respect to the stock of existing algorithms is below one.
Then the growth just fizzles out.
Right. It behaves just like normal industries. It gets harder over time and it slows down. Now, if the number is exactly one, you get exponential growth, but it's balancing right on a knife edge.
But if it's above one.
If it's above one, that is self-sustaining acceleration. That is your runaway intelligence explosion.
Okay. So how do they actually model getting to that number?
While the paper walks through a progression of models, they start really simple, going back to Jones in 1995, where it's just human R&D labor producing algorithmic improvements.
Very straightforward. Humans do work. Algorithms get better.
Right. But then they introduce the baseline, RSI model recursive self-improvement. This adds AI capabilities, which they label as C.
And this is the core feedback loop. Algorithms improve capabilities, and then those capabilities turn around and improve the algorithms.
Exactly. But here's where it gets really interesting.
Yeah, this part blew my mind.
The paper makes this vital conceptual move. They divide AI capabilities into two totally different categories, narrow and broad.
Which makes so much sense when you think about it.
It does. Because AI might get incredibly good at optimizing its own AI R&D benchmarks, like writing code or tweaking neural nets. Those are narrow capabilities.
And those narrow capabilities feed directly back into the loop.
Right, but then you have broad capabilities. These are the skills needed for economically valuable real-world work, things like managing a supply chain or making a medical diagnosis.
And in their graph, those broad capabilities just kind of dangle off the side.
They dangle. They are outputs, not inputs. So you could have a situation where an AI is a complete genius at optimizing its own code in a lab, but it doesn't get any better at doing actual valuable work for us.
A mathematical explosion that nobody in the real economy even notices.
Exactly. And even inside that lab, the loop can easily break. The authors talk about these growth spurts. AI might accelerate one specific sub-algorithm.
Like it gets really good at data sorting.
Right. Massive growth spurt there. But then it stalls out completely because it hits a bottleneck.
What kind of bottlenecks are we talking about here?
Things that an AI physically cannot optimize on its own, like human labor for specific evaluations or experimental compute, training compute, or just raw data. Any of those can break the loop.
Because it doesn't matter how smart the algorithm is if you don't have the literal computer chips to run the experiment.
Exactly. And this brings in some great work from Davidson et al., also from 2026, about economic feedback loops. Because it's not just about algorithms improving algorithms. It's about money.
Right. AI makes revenue. Revenue buys more compute and data.
Right. And for the acceleration to happen, the condition becomes the dominant eigenvalue of a feedback matrix exceeding one, which is a lot of math jargon.
But basically means the financial engine has to compound, too.
Yes. If we connect this to the bigger picture, it grounds this whole wild tech theory in very harsh economic reality. You have to pay for the data centers.
OK, so that brings us to the absolute centerpiece of the paper. The calibration. This is the headline. They actually crunched the numbers to see where we are.
Yeah, they used the Epoch Capabilities Index, or the ECI, to measure current AI progress.
And they found the threshold for an explosion. For self-sustaining acceleration to happen, one additional ECI unit needs to buy you at least a 15% higher AI R&D productivity.
That's the bar to clear, 15%. At
the current reality, their back-of-the-envelope estimate is sitting at about 9%.
Right, 9%. So
the loop is not closed, not yet.
No, it's not. But let's break down exactly how they got that 9% figure, because the math is fascinating. First, they observed that algorithmic efficiency is basically tripling every year right now. And by regressing the ECI on log compute, they
found that the elasticity of capabilities to algorithmic efficiency is around 6.5.
Okay, can we give a really concrete example of what that looks like?
Sure. Let's say Anthropic releases a minor update. They move from Claude Opus 4.7 to 4.8. Right. For the intelligence explosion to be real, moving from 4.7 to 4.8 would need to make Anthropic's own researchers exactly
15% faster at their jobs.
Wow. Okay, but there is a massive, honest caveat that the authors put in the paper here, right?
Yes, a very big one. They have almost no hard evidence for that middle term, the elasticity of research effort to sweep abilities.
Right, because how do you actually measure how much faster an AI makes a human researcher?
Exactly.
Which leads right into the major disagreement in the data. And we really shouldn't smooth this over. That 9% number, where did it come from?
It's derived from anthropic engineers' self-reporting. They reported a 4x uplift in the Claude mythos preview system card.
Wait. So the main input for the calibration of this world altering theory is just a self-report. Engineers saying, yeah, I feel four times faster.
Pretty much. And the authors of the METR paper admit this is very likely an overestimate. Human perception is tricky.
Especially because there's actual data contradicting it. You brought up that other METR randomized controlled trial, the RCT by Becker, Rush, Barnes, and Rain.
Right. In that trial, they gave experienced open source developers early 2025 AI tools, and the developers using the AI were actually slower at completing their tasks.
Slower.
Yes, objectively slower. But, and this is the crazy part, they fervently believed they were faster.
That is wild. I mean, I sort of get it. If I ask an AI to write a Python script and it spits it out in two seconds, I feel like a genius. I feel super productive.
Right, until you spend the next three hours hunting down a subtle hallucination in the code.
Exactly. You're trading writing time for debugging time, and debugging is way harder.
Now, there are alternative ways they try to measure this. The paper also brings in Quietl's time horizon measure.
Right, looking at how long a task the AI can handle on its own.
Yeah, they reported a 40-hour time horizon. And there was a claim that by April 2026, the mythos preview system was beating human researchers 64% of the time on these longer tasks.
So you really just have to sit with that tension. You have one real randomized trial showing humans are slower with AI, and then this other claim of a 64% win rate on 40-hour tasks.
It's a huge gap between perceived productivity and actual objective output.
So to figure out how fast this elasticity is actually moving in reality, the authors bring in an outside check. And this is the Manso, Fu, and Thompson paper, the AI-enabled scientific frontier.
And the scale of this data set is just massive. They assembled 2,507 head-to-head comparisons between AI and other traditional techniques.
Across 27 different scientific disciplines.
Exactly. Not just coding, chemistry, physics, biology. And the results are incredibly nuanced.
And what did they find?
Well, AI very often beats traditional statistics. But it costs significantly more compute to do it.
Using a sledgehammer to crack a nut.
Right. But worse than that, in nearly a quarter of all cases, 25% of the time, the AI is both more expensive AD, worse than the traditional method.
Wait, really? A quarter of the time?
Yes. And that fraction has been stubbornly stable for a decade.
That's a lot of wasted compute.
But here is the flip side. When you look at complex scientific computing like simulating physics or weather AI has historically underperformed. But since 2020, it now actually wins more than half of those head to head comparisons.
OK, so it is making real breakthroughs there.
Yes. But this raises an important question. How much of this current AI progress is genuine cognitive acceleration like the math actually getting smarter versus just throwing massive, expensive amounts of compute at a problem until it works?
Because if it's just brute forcing the problem, we're going to hit a wall.
Yeah.
Which brings us to the bottlenecks, the arguments against this whole acceleration.
Right. The real world constraints.
Yeah. Like running out of global GDP to finance these investments or diminishing returns on just how much an algorithm can optimize itself.
And there's also the strong argument that most of what we call algorithmic progress right now is actually just data progress in disguise.
Oh, that's interesting. Like, it's not the code getting better. It's just that we fed it more of the Internet.
Exactly. And once you run out of high quality human data, the progress might just stall out.
And then there's the physical infrastructure. We can't ignore the politics and the power grid.
No, you really can't. The paper points this out just as an impartial physical reality. In the first three months of 2026 alone, roughly 20 U.S. data center projects were canceled.
Just in three months.
Yeah. And over a three year period, that's $85 billion worth of canceled physical infrastructure.
$85 billion.
Right. It doesn't matter how good your recursive self-improvement algorithm is if you can't get the zoning permits to build the power plant to run the servers.
Exactly. The intelligence explosion is basically waiting on local city council approval.
Basically, yeah.
So we've walked through the graphs, the math, the bottlenecks. What does this paper actually conclude with? What do they want?
Honestly, it's a very dry, unglamorous wish list.
No dramatic warnings about the end of the world?
Not at all. They just want AI companies to publicly share specific measurements. Things like the exact fraction of their lab R&D expenditures going to different inputs.
Like how much they spend on human researchers versus raw compute.
Right. They want transparency so that this entire debate stops being a matter of PR vibes and opinions and just becomes a matter of tracking a spreadsheet.
So what does this all mean if we take a step back and synthesize this deep dive?
Well, it's an economics paper about the most hyped question in human history. And its biggest contribution is just discipline rather than drama.
Right. The profound takeaway isn't simply, oh, there's no explosion yet. It's that we finally have a real framework and an actual number attached to the question.
Exactly. We can actually measure it now.
But I want to leave you, the listener, with a final provocative thought to mull over. We talked about how the metric for this self-sustaining explosion right now relies on human researchers self-reporting how fast they're working.
Right, the 4X uplift.
So what happens when the AI starts filling out those self-reports?
Oh, wow.
Right. If an AI system is optimizing its own benchmarks, are we really measuring the speed of the machine? Or are we just measuring the human ego attached to it, perfectly reflected back at us by an AI designed to please us?
That is a slightly terrifying thought. Are we just measuring a hallucination of progress?
Exactly. It's definitely something to think about. Thank you all for joining us on this deep dive. Keep your eyes on the elasticities, not just the headlines. We'll catch you next time.